behind-the-scenes of dangerous
encounters with Brady bar snake bite
I've gotten strange reports about this
population of pythons living in caves in
Indonesia reports that people would go
into these caves and find mini giant
pythons what's something I definitely
wanted to check out there may be more
than I captured a lot of big snakes I
captured a lot of big pythons
but I've never had an encounter like I
did in the cave in Indonesia the cave
was it was a horrible place I really
don't like that
it was knee-deep to waste the liquefied
bat guano on top of it you've got
maggots flies scorpions roaches bats
Caves are dangerous places
you throw in giant snakes and man you
got really dangerous places is the
oxygen level there
here we're about I don't know maybe a
hundred meters in the case and I looked
across the cab and I saw a giant saying
something totally unexpected
you got it whoa I mean this is what
we've been waiting I mean this is why we
go to the ends of the earth to find
these types of animals and have these
types of interactions but when it
happens man it's so unexpected that's a
big - whoa I'm trying to secure the head
the snakes all over the place the snake
is now in a very defensive frame of mind
because something has it the snake feels
like it's being attacked yeah but he's
gonna come back and bite and before I
know it before I even realize what had
happened it is thrown a coil around my
legs down low I looked over and I saw it
had a coil around mark - so the snake
had both of us
wrap in its powerful coil and then it
happened
bang ah that thing hit me on the back of
the leg yeah you got me good he's go the
thing Hey now they've got dozens of
these strong recurved teeth which they
just drive into your flesh let go let go
drove its teeth in and then just started
ripping downward where's his head I mean
he was like throwing some steak knives
into my leg and then just pulling
ripping downward I got I got a bad bite
Oh where's his head we didn't find that
head somebody else was gonna get a bite
and I knew if it was me
I couldn't I couldn't remain conscious I
was gonna be down and out if I had to
experience what I just went through I
gotta get out of this stuff I mean I'm
bleeding for the longest time Python
teeth has worked their way to the
surface they broke off deep down in my
flesh I feel something kind of trickling
my pants and reach back there felt like
a little toothpick I'd pull it out would
be Python teeth from the biter how bad
does it look
oh yeah it's bad it was a snake
encounter that I'll never forget and
the record books
[Music]